la articulación de la cadera tiene dos
huesos que encajan como una bola en una
cavidad la bola es la parte superior del
fémur y se llama cabeza femoral
la cavidad de la pelvis se llama
acetábulo
por lo general se realiza una
sustitución total de cadera si sufre un
dolor intenso causado por artritis
lesiones u otras enfermedades que dañan
la cadera
durante el procedimiento la articulación
de la cadera será sustituida por partes
nuevas artificiales llamadas prótesis la
parte de la cavidad de la prótesis es
una copa llamada componente acetabular
y la parte de la bola se llama
componente femoral
para iniciar el procedimiento el
cirujano hará una incisión sobre la
cadera
una vez alcanzada la articulación de la
cadera el cirujano dislocara la
articulación
se eliminará cualquier cartílago o hueso
dañado en el acetábulo
la cavidad que puede estar deformada se
re moldeará para que se ajuste el
componente acetabular a continuación el
componente acetabular se colocará en la
cavidad se pueda usar cemento o
tornillos especiales para mantenerlo en
su posición para preparar el fémur el
cirujano extirpar a la cabeza femoral
el extremo cortado se moldeará para que
se ajuste el componente femoral a
continuación el componente femoral se
insertará en el fémur se puede mantener
en su posición con cemento
en este punto el cirujano colocará la
bola del componente femoral en la nueva
cavidad con la nueva articulación de
cadera en su posición
el cirujano probará su movimiento y
estabilidad al final del procedimiento
la incisión se cerrará con puntos o
grapas
para obtener más información sobre la
sustitución total de cadera hablé con su
proveedor de atención médica